convaincre mot d'ordre les socialistes
pour ce scrutin européen convaincu sur
le programme bien sûr mais aussi sur le
fait que l'élection ne doit pas servir à
sanctionner le gouvernement français ce
scrutin c'est pas le troisième tour des
municipales c'est pas un sondage
grandeur nature on se fait plaisir sans
regarder quel est le pouvoir qu'on met
en place et ça n'est pas non plus une
mini présidentielle dans un département
comme celui ci celui des yvelines si on
coupe les frontières si on sort la
france de l'euro si on veut isoler la
france eh bien nous perdrons des emplois
parce que dans un département comme
celui ci beaucoup d emplois dépendent
d'entreprises qui sont venus investir
dans notre pays présente aux mureaux
mercredi dernier la tête de liste
socialiste en ile de france était
accompagné de ses colistiers guillaume
balas déjà conseiller régional et michel
christophoul seul yvelinoise recenser
tous deux préfère garder la tête froide
face aux sondages qui donnent leur
formation troisième derrière le fn et
l'ump les sondages ont municipal donne
un bon score pour le parti socialiste et
on a vu le résultat donc j'allais dire
pour présenter que puisqu'ils sont
mauvais peut-être contraint bon ce
moment ça m'indiffère totalement ce qui
est important c'est l'humilité les
sondages sont une photographie ça n'est
pas une prévision est donc c'est double
70% des personnes en france sont des
soies ne connaissent pas l'orientation
politique du parlement européen soit
pense qu'il est à gauche donc c'est
quand même extraordinaire de finalement
d'avoir à assumer nous socialistes
français au parlement européen qui est
majoritairement à droite et largement
une commission européenne est
majoritairement à droite incarnée par
son président sur le fond le ps évoque
dans son programme un salaire minimum
européen une harmonisation du droit des
travailleurs une taxation de la finance
ou encore des investissements dans de
grands projets industriels